one in custody so at the beginning you
know we meet officer ward it seems to be
a pretty normal world
everybody's just trying to get along and
have a good life all of the races are
different just because they're different
doesn't mean anybody's better or worse
than anybody it's LA right now it just
happens to be orcs and elves this film
in a lot of ways is really a story of a
friendship
it's about officer Ward and officer
Jacobi they're both LAPD officers but
they couldn't be more different joel
edgerton playing an ORAC joel's playing
a character that sort of worked really
hard to get somewhere in life and be
something Jacoby is the first orc on the
force he spent his whole life trying to
be as human as possible and he really
wants to fit in with the human society
boy it's okay you don't like them now
I'm not out here to be your friend I
need to know if [ __ ] pop up that you got
my back we had amnon show us in route we
show up on a call certainly wait for the
cavalry
we are the cavalry and we realize that
there is a massively powerful artifact
that's a magic it's sort of like a
nuclear weapon
that's whatever you want you wanna be
taller or shorter you want ten million
dollars you're not stealing it why we
are gonna be in a lot of trouble we are
taking the wand and the orchid eyes and
you got a big decision and we have a lot
of hate on us because everybody wants to
get their hands on it
listen this is happening go imagine one
you have to secure it you gotta get out
of this neighborhood they're gonna kill
you tell me and that's what a stupid
shit's gonna start it'll teach that of
the Academy no they do not
[Music]
the most important thing about this film
is the relationship between Jolin will
to incredible actors together it's
supercharged humor grab it like you
stole it
yeah get you some ice cream later it's
gritty hardcore action
gonna keep coming it's wildly unique
let's do it
[Music]
some days I can't get out of my head
that's just the dark side
[Music]
I'm assuming this doesn't end well
you
you